bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle édition du journal en cette
veille de noël voici les principaux
titres de ce 24 décembre
magny les hameaux a reçu le trèfle fit
au site et 2014 pour son action en
faveur de la lutte contre les herbicides
et pesticides
la période de fêtes de fin d'année
souvent remplis de joie mais pas
toujours nous avons suivi le travail des
écoutants évinois de l'association sos
amitié noël une fête importante pour les
chrétiens nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants avec le père fabrice
du ahly vicaire du groupe paroissial
saint quentin saint victor qui comprend
les communes de guyancourt et montigny
le bretonneux mais tout d'abord on va
parler économie pour démarrer ce journal
les chiffres de l'emploi pour le mois de
novembre ont été dévoilées en cette fin
de matinée fin novembre 2014 le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi inscrits à pôle
emploi en catégorie à s'établit à 660
milles 550 personnes en ile de france ce
nombre augmente de 1,4 pour cent par
rapport à la fin août afin d' octobre
2014 sur un an la hausse est de 6 5% le
département toujours dans la catégorie à
part une progresse lui de 1 % et toutes
catégories confondues a b et c le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi est stable en ile
de france et dans les yvelines en
novembre 2014 par rapport à octobre 2014
le 16 décembre dernier la commune de
magny les hameaux s'est vu remettre le
diplôme du trèfle phyto au site et 2014
ce diplôme récompense l'engagement par
la commune depuis 2009 pour réduire
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires ces produits était
notamment utilisé pour le désherbage la
commune a baissé de 80 % sa consommation
je vais vous d'écouter raymond besco il
est conseillé mal en charge notamment du
développement durable
aujourd'hui on n'utilise quasiment plus
rien à part quelques produits comme des
anti limaces
mais le reste des tout est fait à la
main par les soit par nos agents soit en
partenariat avec des associations
locales le zéro phyto est accessible
alors c'est un problème de conviction et
de pratique dans les jardins aujourd'hui
le principal problème c'est
l'utilisation par les particuliers de
ces produits chimiques dans leur jardin
toujours dans le domaine de
l'environnement pour les vacances de
noël la ville de versailles propose une
foule d'activités de saison
traditionnelle la patinoire seule
différence celle ci n'est pas en glace
mais en synthétique c'est une patinoire
écologique cela n'empêche pas les
patinoires débutants et confirmés de
s'amuser comme ont pu le constater que
le run parfait et le des moines
pour le premier week-end des vacances de
noël ils sont nombreux patineurs
expérimentés ou débutants à s'élancer
sur les 300 m² de la patinoire de
versailles parfois non sans mal mais
c'est pour leur plus grand bonheur
qu'ils testent cette patinoire sans
glace ce sont des plaques employés fidh
donc on n'a pas besoin d'utiliser ni
d'eau ni discutée ni glycol donc on a
une grosse économie d'énergie et les
plaques sont réutilisables à nombre de
fois très importante ce qui fait que sur
le plan écologique par rapport aux
patinoires classique on a beaucoup moins
d'énergie que
les patins sont les mêmes que ceux
utilisés pour le authier mais à part ça
rien ne change les rires les pleurs les
petites ou grosses frayeurs les parents
aux aguets même les crêpes après
l'effort sont là verdict au bout d'une
heure de glissades qu'elle est très
sympa
puisque enfin si on n'est pas allé
provisionnel pas besoin de vendre à
patine mais ça va quand même de pouvoir
rebâtir on débute avec les enfants alors
pour nous ça change pas grand chose donc
amenés sur nous dit que c'est écologique
on est pour on vient ça près pas tout à
fait la même sensation que je vous
patinoire normal ceci temps ça permet de
rentrer en contact avec ce qu'on appelle
communément la lys j'ai gardé mon petit
fils thomas et
c'est l'occasion de lui faire faire un
peu de sport il est de commencer a
ajouté ici un petit peu aux sports de 10
ans qu'on al'intention membres de sports
d'hiver dans pas longtemps les
températures douces pour la saison
hivernale ne feront pas retenir cette
patinoire synthétique ouverte jusqu'au 4
janvier et en cas de chute pas de risque
de ce maudit
allez un tout autre sujet moment de
magie pour les uns c'est pas de fêtes de
fin d'année laisse parfois place à la
déprime et à la solitude pour certains
une solitude qui est la cause d'un appel
sur trois à sos amitié dans les yvelines
depuis 2000 une antenne existe à saint
germain en laye une trentaine de
bénévoles s'y relaient chaque jour pour
être à l'écouté violaine thorez elodie
moines
aucun temps mort le téléphone sonne
constamment dans les locaux des sceaux s
amitié à saint-germain-en-laye l'unique
antennes des yvelines les bénévoles sont
là pour écouter écouter la solitude des
personnes âgées ou le désespoir des
autres je me sens tellement seul
on dirait que tout le monde à quelqu'un
sauf moi
j'ai l'impression d'être
invisible au monde
transparent
bénévoles ici pendant sept ans nagui a
vu certaines choses évoluer les jeunes
appellent de plus en plus souvent
des problèmes de suicides des problèmes
de non compréhension des parents des
problèmes de
deux copains copines
et ils passent pas le dire
ils ne peuvent le dire ni à un
professionnel de santé ni aux parents et
encore moins aux camarades de classe par
peur des moqueries chez sos amitié basée
sur l'anonymat et la stricte
confidentialité ces ados ne sont ni
juger ni conseillée mais parfois
simplement orientée vers les personnes
compétentes
je suis perdu
vous ne comprenez pas ce qui vous arrive
j'avais peur que vous ne soyez pas là ce
soir
mais si messieurs je suis là
je vous téléphone souvent en ce moment
mais il n'ya que vous qui m'écoutent et
c'est une période difficile pour vous
al'approche des fêtes les bénévoles sont
plus que jamais sollicitée à
saint-germain-en-laye ils sont 32 à se
répartir les permanences de quatre
heures les appels à varie entre 5
minutes et une heure voire plus et tous
les quinze jours une réunion avec une
psychologue leur permet de débriefer les
appelle un peu lourd malgré tout en
ile-de-france seulement trois appels sur
quatre n'aboutissent pas faute d coûtant
au bout du fil nous faudrait beaucoup
plus des coûts tant sur l'île de france
nous somme de 160 sur toute la france
nous sommes mis 6 en écoutant et il nous
en faudrait beaucoup alors s'il ya des
personnes qui veulent être bénévole qui
nous contactent
je vous remercie pour votre écoute
madame et je me permets vous souhaiter
un joyeux noël
joyeux noël pour vous et vos enfants
messieurs merci
la
voilà maintenant parler de la tradition
de noël avec vos pairs fabrique séduit
vous êtes vicaire du groupement
paroissial saint quentin saint victor
bonsoir doit d'abord une première
réaction sur le reportage convient de
voir au sein de locaux de sos amitié
donc dans les yvelines est ce que vous
ressentez vous au sein de vos paroisses
que la période de fin d'année c'est une
période un peu délicate peut-être les
gens viennent chercher du réconfort
moral effectivement c'est quelque chose
qu'on constate souvent dans nos
paroisses de voir que c'est un moment
qui cristallise les souffrances les
blessures que peuvent porter les
personnes en particulier tout ce qui est
blessures familiales à la fois la
solitude parfois des familles désunies
au moment où les familles vont se réunir
et bien et est renvoyé le fait que
parfois des familles ne peuvent pas se
réunir et on sent on sent que c'est
douloureux est aussi source d'angoissé
pour beaucoup de gens donc ça veut dire
que vous voyez arriver de nouvelles
personnes que vous ne connaissiez pas
avant on voit pas majoritairement des
nouvelles personnes mais on voit le soir
de noël dont on sait qu'il y aura
beaucoup de personnes qu'on voit pas
forcément le reste de l'année ce qui
viennent parce qu'ils sont seuls et ce
qu'ils viennent aussi parce qu'il ya la
tradition que le soir de noël on va à la
messe mais ça je serai pas très bien
vous dire mais on voit dans l'est dans
les discussions qu'on peut avoir avec
les personnes que pour beaucoup c'est à
la fois une joie et en même temps une
appréhension cette période de noël quand
on regarde ce reportage sur les
spéciales amitié vous me disiez qu'il
existait un service sos prière oui il ya
des gens qui effectivement appel sos
amitié pour pouvoir discuter et puis on
a aussi un service qui s'appelle sos
prière malheureusement je n'ai pas le
numéro sur moi on pourra peut-être le
mettre sur votre page internet
où les gens peuvent appeler et il ya des
pertes des écoutants qui vont prier avec
eux c'est à dire dire eh bien ce que
vous portez nos comme croyant bien on va
leur mettre ensemble à dieu puisque
souvent ces personnes disent je ne suis
plus capable de prier seul on va parler
avec vous de la symbolique de noël mais
avant je voudrais quand même vous faire
réagir sur cette polémique a commencé à
naître autour de la présence des crèches
dans les lieux publics le 3 décembre
dernier le tribunal de nantes a interdit
la crèche de noël au conseil général du
conseil général de vendée est ce que ça
vous a surpris je prends ça absurde pour
tout vous dire tout ça absurde parce que
c'est avoir peur de son ombre fête noël
ça fait j'ai regardé avant de venir au
moins depuis l'an 354 qu'en france on
fête noël et que noël est liée à un
événement qui est la naissance de jésus
christ alors qu'on veuille le
déchristianisée absolument me semble
vouloir ôter la tradition de là où elle
est tout simplement on est en 2014 après
jésus christ si on veut être cohérent il
faut l'être jusqu'au bout si
effectivement y voir aucun signe
religieux dans notre pays c'est ce que
c'est ce que dit la loi de 1905 sur la
séparation des églises et de l'état une
séparation très claire et aucun problème
avec cette séparation je pense même
qu'elle est un bien mais par contre
n'ayons pas peur de notre tradition de
notre histoire on est en 2014 après
jésus christ si on pense qu'il faut
aucune référence à la crèche de noël
c'est au-delà du symbole religieux c'est
la tradition bien sûr l'événement noël
renvoie à la naissance de jésus christ
qui était dans une crèche et qui
renvoient à des tas de symbole le pauvre
qui n'a pas d'abri
et bien jésus n'a pas eu d'abri au
moment de la nuit de naissance le petit
enfant l'accueil du plus faible tout ça
renvoie à des symboles qui sont pas faux
pas du tout religieux mais qui mais qui
font partie
profondément de notre tradition
française de notre histoire française
donc pas demain c'est pas un comptable
incompatibles parlons avec la laïcité
non je ne pense vraiment pas alors là la
symbolique de noël justement pour la
communauté catholique pour les chrétiens
en général qu'est ce que ça ça signifie
la symbolique c'est la naissance de
jésus christ et ce pour un chrétien la
naissance de jésus christ c'est dieu se
fait homme vous voyez c'est un événement
c'est l'événement décisif
dieu le tout autre auquel l'homme n'a
pas accès choisi de venir rejoindre
l'homme l'humanité en se faisant lui
même hobbes et c'est un événement
tellement décisif comme je vous disais
que on a commencé à compter de puisse
dans notre dans notre société chrétienne
ou dans notre vieille europe chrétienne
on a compté depuis cet événement là et
tous les ans les chrétiens commémorent
l'événement fondateur de leur religion
alors les chrétiens à comprendre c'est
les catholiques et les protestants est
ce qu'il ya une autre religion qui
partagent ce symbole la nativité alors
les catholiques les protestants et les
orthodoxes tous les chrétiens
puisque c'est par définition le
christianisme c'est qu'il se réfère à
l'événement cristal est venue de jésus
christ sur terre pendant cette période
pour un prêtre pour le vicaire que vous
êtes est ce que c'est une période
d'activité de suractivité oui c'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est prêtre
et vicaire comme vous sur cette période
de fin d'année de noël mais juste avant
de venir vous voir j'étais en train de
répéter avec la chorale le conte de noël
qui commencera la messe de noël ce soir
ce matin je finalise m mais homélie pour
les différentes messes et puis c'est
aussi une période où beaucoup de gens se
préparent aussi spirituellement en
voulant recevoir le sacrement de
confession de réconciliation et donc
c'est aussi une période où on confesse
beaucoup de gens qui viennent nous
rencontrer pour recevoir le pardon de
dieu donc c'est vraiment la pâte très
importante très symboliquement
importante pour les catholiques
peut-être plus que pâques je sais pas si
je la mettrais plus d'un mois qu'il n'y
a pas deux événements majeurs
c'est noël et pâques en termes de rythme
noël est un peu plus calme parce qu en
fait un événement alors capable quand
vont s'enchaîner les jours saints du
jeudi saint du vendredi saint du samedi
saint en terme de préparation il ya plus
de travail que ce soit les deux
événements sont sont les événements
essentiels alors traditionnellement il
ya des maîtres c'est évidemment ce 24
décembre au soir il ya 18 ans trois ans
glisse sa victoire et une autre à 18 ans
tente aussi à 50,1 des sources et à
22h30 il ya la nuit de noël au cap saint
jacques est ce que c'est des moments qui
sont toujours très suivies en plus la
messe de minuit à minuit à ça n'existe
plus beaucoup maintenant mais alors nous
sur la paroisse on a fait le choix de
pas mettre de metz à minuit minuit pour
préserver le sommeil de chacun mais
c'est des mecs qui sont très suivis je
vous dis à 18h30 nos deux églises qui
ont fait deux messes dans deux églises
différentes à la même heure ce qui est
c'est inhabituel ses conseils dans une
église ne rentrerait absolument pas nous
deux églises l'église saint-victor de
guyancourt à l'église saint quentin les
sources à montigny tout près de téléfilm
exactement ce qu'ils veulent aller donc
22h38 saint jacques et puis j'ai besoin
jacques cap-saint-jacques pardon et puis
jeudi 25 décembre à 10 heures à l'église
saint victor et 11h30 à 50,1 des sources
vous êtes combien de prêtres et vicaire
à vous partager le secteur jeux passion
pain comme ça alors on est trois prêtres
sur ce groupement paroissial et on va se
répartir et bien les 5 ms en veillant
aussi la messe de la nuit on y sera les
trois prêtres ensemble parce que c'est
un peu le grand rassemblement avec les
chrétiens qu'on puisse vivre ce temps
familial ensemble et un dernier mot
avant de vous quitter de vous laisser
vous préparer pour la m alors là on va
aller un peu plus loin on va aller vers
la fin du mois de janvier avec le
festival d'art sacré qui aura lieu à
l'église saint victoret échos
cap-saint-jacques de quoi s'agit-il d'un
festival qui a lieu du 30 janvier au 2
février il ya beaucoup de choses il ya
des concerts des expositions c'est assez
riche l'idée c'est qu'il ya un lien
entre le bo et le divin l'a souvent tous
fait l'expérience que
lorsqu'il ya quelque chose de beau et
bien on voit qu'il ya quelque chose de
plus grand que nous mêmes et donc c'est
de pouvoir et bien pendant trois jours
utiliser tout ce qui est art à travers
la musique le théâtre
des contes et bien permettre à chacun de
goûter le beau et peut-être de se
rapprocher un peu de dieu à travers ça
ce sera du 30 janvier au 2 février mais
d'ici là il ya les messes de noël merci
beaucoup faire un fabrice séduit d'être
venu sur le plateau du 7-8 le journal
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour cette fin
d'année bonnes fêtes de noël je crois
que c'est ce qu'on souhaite
habituellement à cette période et pour
faire la transition avec le sujet qui va
suivre est ce que vous êtes gourmand on
peut appliquer en plus gourmands peut
être dit qu'elle peut être gros et bûche
de noël j'aime c'est pas mon idée ça
s'est inversé
en tout cas d'être né sur le plateau les
bûches de noël en tout cas pour beaucoup
c'est le dessert star de notables pour
les repas de fêtes de fin d'année au
chocolat aux fruits ou biscuits ou
glacés elle se décline sous toutes les
recettes et pour que vous puissiez avoir
le choix les pâtissiers saint quentinois
redouble d'activité c'est le cas de
franck de grosses et ceux de son équipe
mélanie poquet elodie moines ont vu et
déguster pour nous ces fameuses but
rien qu'à le voir on en a l'eau à la
bouche du chocolat à foison qui va aller
recouvrer les buts de franck de bosses
et la recette fait elle aussi saliver
alors cette bûche et labège 2 pour
bûcher provence c'est une crème
mascarpone
dany avec un club de cassis et un
biscuit yeah man 2 citrons les bûches
sont un vrai produit de noël franck
dobosz et écoulent en trois jours
seulement ici son entreprise ne connaît
pas la crise avec la vente de chocolats
les fêtes de fin d'année représentent
40% du chiffre d'affaires sur la période
novembre janvier
ici quatre bus différentes sont préparés
entre légèreté après un repas parfois
bien copieux et tradition la
particularité de le bus ce sont des
bûches qui sont très légères ce sont d
entre eux mais qu'ils sont refaits
embûches mais on a aussi les bûches les
bouches qui roulait à la crème au beurre
aussi ce sont des bus qui sont
traditionnelles qui selon vous doit
faire obligatoirement pour le réveillon
parce que certaines personnes certains
clients préfèrent la bûche
traditionnelle
et décoré et emballée ces bus
n'attendent qu'une chose régaler nos
palais rassurez vous il n'y a plus que
quelques heures à patienter
et justement est-ce que la bûche fera
partie de votre repas de noël qu'allez
vous mangez ce soir réveillon de noël ou
demain c'est la question que nous sommes
allez vous poser dans les rues de 50 ans
jean et vous allez voir que les
habitants sont assez classiques au
réveillon des pagnes au poivre et
jeudi nous mangeons une dinde farcie aux
marrons et aux figues apéro avec des
canapés de l'impudeur de crabes anchois
c'est moi j'ai des saint jacques en
entrée en carpaccio ensuite du chapon
fermier avec des légumes et puis et
fromages et bûche très traditionnelle y
aura des huîtres du foie gras du saumon
enfin de toutes les choses classiques on
entre et c'est prévu une salade avec du
magret de canard du foie gras des
gésiers de canard des petits pignons de
pin un chapon du saumon poissons fumés
et puis des fruits de mer crabe tourteau
langoustines et le lendemain ben écoutez
un petit chapeau avec du foie gras voilà
et oui voilà on ne se refuse rien bon
appétit en tout cas à toutes ces
personnes le château de breteuil à
chevreuse et reste ouvert pendant les
vacances de fin d'année des visites
guidées sont organisées mais également
des séances de contes des séances de
contes très imagé comme vous allez
pouvoir le constater
irène et natalia ne sont pas simplement
conteuse ici au château de breteuil
certes elle redonne une seconde vie à
ces comptes de france et d'ailleurs mais
elle raconte en voix et en musique et
n'hésite pas surtout à faire participer
le public ça nous a plu la visite de
breteuil aussi c'était sympa un conte
vivant très animé c'était très bien été
faite de participer d'entraîner les
enfants ça très bien c'était assez
original et puis c'est bien d'avoir de
vrais conteuse et de faire participer
les enfants et le public à breteuil
pendant toutes les vacances de noël le
château est ouvert les journées la
visite et des ateliers couture et de
comptes s'y déroulent des contes de noël
aux divers ou plus traditionnellement
autour de charles perrault avec toujours
le même objectif faire voyager
l'imaginaire il faut
une bonne dose d'humour de savoir faire
et puis il faut captivé les enfants avec
des débris des iphone très bien choisir
les histoires les séances de contes on
joue tous les jours à 16h30 écoutez bien
alors c'était il ya très très longtemps
dans les sapins ont des corps avec ce
que vous trouvez dans les jardins des
noix des pommes de toutes les couleurs
ce jour là c'était le soir de noël on
avait décoré dans la maison il y en
avait fait le grand ménage ce qui fait
que toutes les petites araignées s'était
pas et est parti se réfugier dans le
grenier dans les caves dans les recoins
quand tout fut silencieux que tout le
monde fut couché et qui avait envie de
voir ce magnifique sapin décoré elles
sont descendus et ont sauté de branche
en branche depuis coupe est partout
partout partout et l on essaie tous
pleurent toile d'araignée partout sur le
sapin j'avais pour connaître la suite de
ses comptes rendez vous donc au château
de breteuil elle et du sport maintenant
dans le cadre de la préparation de
l'équipe de france handisport en vue des
championnats d'europe 2015 le club de
montigny le bretonneux a reçu ses
joueurs de l'équipe de france pour un
match amical c'était vendredi dernier au
gymnase ladoumègue anthony rech david
charpentier
s'ils connaissent des difficultés en
championnat les volleyeurs de montigny
voit dans ce match amical face à
l'équipe de france des sourds une
occasion de se détacher du combat pour
le maintien face à un adversaire de
prestige c'est un challenge parce que
bon on les connaît pas on ne connaît pas
on sait pas quel est leur niveau mais on
a envie quand même de bien faire
évidemment
voilà c'est quand même l'équipe de
franges des sceaux en juillet 2015 paris
accueillera le championnat d'europe des
sourds la sélection officielle ne
tombera qu'en février il reste donc
encore quelques places à prendre dans le
groupe tricolore une équipe de france
ambitieuse après sa sixième place aux
mondiaux de 2011 en bulgarie
voilà c'est effectivement d'avoir une
meilleure stratégie la meilleure
relation entre les joueurs pour être
beaucoup plus régulier parce que dix
jours de compétition avec des matches
tous les jours
c'est important
l'objectif moi personnellement il est
clair c'est la meilleure place possible
mais bon après bien sûr dans les quatre
premiers
ce serait le mieux pour être qualifié
directement pour les jeux olympiques si
cette rencontre et amicale elle a une
saveur toute particulière pour vous
aviez bnr c'est un peu le retour aux
sources pour le capitaine de l'équipe de
france passé par montigny pendant trois
saisons nous expliquer ce qu'il sent les
vibrations du sang les mouvements par
contre ils sont pas le bruit de la balle
il l'a pas et il entend pas à droite à
gauche et des fois on a des anecdotes
tout
tout le monde lui crier parce qu'on le
prenait comme un joueur oui j'ai la
balle c'est moi oui pour le dit mais
pourquoi on l'avait la balle et il se
retournait en rigolant en dix ans et je
n'ai pas entendu
battu 3 sets 1 l'équipe de france
dispose encore de six mois pour trouver
la bonne formule qui lui permettra de se
hisser sur le podium des championnats
d'europe
ce journal est presque terminée avant de
nous quitter deux informations pratiques
les vendredis 26 décembre dès vendredi 2
janvier les guichets de la préfecture à
versailles et des sous préfecture de
mantes la jolie rambouillet et
saint-germain-en-laye seront ouverts au
public aux horaires habituels par contre
les services du conseil général seront
eux fermés les 26 décembre et 2 janvier
ce journal est maintenant terminé merci
de votre attention en mon nom et en
celui de la d'ensemble de la rédaction
je vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année à la rédaction prend
quelques jours de vacances le direct
sera de retour le lundi à 5 janvier à 18
heures encore bonne fête à vous merci de
nous restait toujours aussi est fidèle
et à très bientôt